imagine you get your first gig in the
NFL and it's in the middle of a pandemic
as a head coach that is what's happening
with our our guests here for the first
time here on the Rich Eisen show pleased
to have this gentleman head coach the
kaolin panthers Matt rule how are you
coach
I'm great thanks for coming here on this
show do you have any any take you've got
kids where would you rather be
quarantine for three and a half months
Las Vegas Nevada or Disneyworld I'd go
to Disney World in a second now you are
you preparing for winning the Super Bowl
by saying that line I think my wife and
I just need a little bit of a break
we go to Disney World and the kids off
to Mickey and say where it will be back
in about three hours pretty much some of
you guys will be we saw your kids at
your introductory press conference how
old are they my son Bryant is 15 and
then my daughters are seven and then
little Leona she's about the track she
turned five oh my gosh
you know in a quarantine situation I've
got an 11 that's a great line I have an
11 9 and a six-year-old at home
coach Wow well planned out yes that's
right we're running through the Disney
Plus offerings day-by-day daily daily
daily day so what is your challenge
right now what's your to use the
coaching term what is your challenge
right now you're in the middle of June
in the middle of everything I think it's
you know it's just um you know trying to
trying to build a team trying to get to
know people kind of you know make
connections build some chemistry well
the team that you know the 90 guys I
think I kind of met 20 of them so just
knowing that if I was walking down the
street and some of our players you guys
we're walking down the street I'm you
know I might not even know who they were
so that's that's you know it's just so
different and especially for a guy like
me I probably a pretty relational guy
you know just trying to make sure I find
a way to connect even even in this
unique time space so when do you think
if you gave me your best guess and I
know coaches deal in certainties so it's
a difficult thing to ask
and when do you think you see people in
person guys guys here I think yeah I
think when training camp starts I mean
III put that in my mind you know like
I'll lose my mind if I keep saying what
could be this it could be that so I just
I just plan out like hey I'm gonna see
everyone July 21st and then if something
happens before then I'll be ecstatic and
if it ever gets delayed I'll just deal
with it as it comes so but I think I
think you know in the support role we'll
see what happens with the NBA in Major
League Baseball you know we're kind of
seeing what happened in the UFC and you
know soccer across you know college
football's getting back together so I
think a lot of a lot more information
probably just as a society even in 30
days yeah I think it's interesting you
use the term lose your mind coach
because every coach I know is a control
freak to the nth degree certainly
professional football coaches are
particularly that and this is just one
huge uncontrollable just the biggest
uncontrollable maybe in the history of
controllables for sports and if we like
to use that term I think is interesting
well it's funny you know as a coach you
you know I find my style I've always
said to my players you know a control
what you can control
but what you could control kind of
teaching like that stoic mindset and
it's a lot easier to say to other people
than it is to do yourself right so all
of a sudden now I get in the same
situation and you know I have to I have
to practice what I've reached and I have
to just sit there and call me look at
everything and you know I really believe
that you know every development has two
sides you know there's a good and bad to
everything so just trying to find the
positives just trying to find the ways
in which you know maybe someday I'll
look back and say hey that was really
cool that that happens you know or it
was good that it happened in that way so
it's it's not easy but I think it's what
we all have to do so in the meantime
let's try and figure out what what it
may be arm and what what what is this
Carolina Panthers team going to look
like with you now in the mix and Joe
Brady who was easily the most
sought-after assistant from the
collegiate ranks with McCaffrey under
the under the on you know all signed
sealed and delivered in in an
unprecedented manner
teddy bridgewater being brought in what
is this team going to look like what can
you tell Panthers fans what it will look
like you know I think we're gonna be an
exciting team on offense you know I
think that Joe has a great system you
know he learned under Sean Payton you
know in New Orleans he did a great job
at LSU we were excited about Teddy and
and you know we have a young group of
receivers Kurtis Samuel deejay more
former first-round draft pick went and
got Robbie Anderson in free agency
you mentioned Christian you know we
think he's someone that can do so many
different things so I think a lot of our
experience a lot of the guys that have
played a lot of football or on that
offensive side so I you know we'll have
to have to get some timing and put some
things together but I'm excited about
where those guys are and then you know I
think defensively you know we had some
key veterans that we know that we built
around and you know cake a short form
you know it's been raw Pro and Shaq
Thompson trade Boston and then went out
and you know who the first team that
ever drafted all defensive players in
the draft and so yeah so so we just you
know I think we're we're gonna be a
young group a fun group you mentioned
Joe we only have one player on the team
that's older than Joe Brady and Joe's 30
or 31
so we'll be young hopefully we'll be fun
team to watch them well I know and again
we had Christian McCaffrey on at the
Super Bowl and he's no Wallflower but he
was kind of at the time and you know he
had just been hired Matt rule here on
the Rich Eisen show asking him the same
question and you know he he kind of
shrugged his shoulders and lamented the
loss of people who were pillars of the
locker room in the franchise from from
obviously Luke Kuechly who had just
retired for reasons that were beyond his
control and Greg Olson then obviously
Cam Newton so what what about that as we
are you're you're talking about
everybody socially distant right now
that aspect of things for you walking
into the first year here yeah I mean I
think I think when you have great great
great players like all I call them in
that you mentioned and and even more you
know we've lost a lot of great defensive
linemen and been players on the other
side of the ball it's hard
you know because you still appreciate
like what they've done appreciate the
way that they did it who they are but
you know this is this is one of those
games that like you know you look back
at the past you appreciate it but you
gotta keep moving forward and you know
Luke's gonna work for us now and and you
know I don't know when he told me he was
leaving he's like I'm sorry I'm sure you
took this job thinking you know I was
going to be one of your guys and I'm
having to leave but you know at the end
of day that's just part that's a part of
life as part of this game and you know
we're one chapter closes you know I
think there's some guys that we really
are excited about that it's gonna be
their opportunities of young draft
excited about their opportunity and you
know I'm one of those guys that I just
say to myself yeah I just want to make
sure that that everything we're doing is
pointing towards the future and I think
the fun part about that is we should be
a fun team to watch you know we're not
the most veteran team but we got a lot
of young guys they're gonna kind of try
to go through it the right way and and
now it's Christians turn and Petty's
turn and Russell who's turned you know
kind of be our leaders and you know
trade boss and Shaq Thompson it's their
turn and I think they're gonna be ready
for it yeah I know especially since you
know they'll have to be in a division
that Tom Brady just joined you want to
talk about veterans Matt Ryan and
obviously Tom Brady and Drew Brees and
and teams that have you know two of them
who have made the Super Bowl in their in
their time obviously the Carolina has as
well but my point is Bridgewater being
and and I love the kid I love and he is
he's 27 but he's a grown man I know what
I'm gonna ask what will sound like
Bridgewater doesn't deserve this I think
he does it's a great opportunity for him
and he's beyond deserves it but he is
replacing somebody who said hey I wanted
to be entertaining an iconic when he
arrived in Carolina and he was so I'll
just ask you point-blank coach was his
Cam Newton not a fit for you is that is
that what happened with him no no I
would I would never say that I think can
do is a great great great quarterback is
a great person and a great leader and
you know his uh his his impact on the
City of Charlotte you know is was was
tremendous both on the field and on the
field so I just think you know you know
I
every decision has to be looked at by
kind of in each time and space and and
where we are right now and and and you
know kind of where where we are as a
team we just felt like hey this is what
this is what we have to do and this was
the right decision for the team so you
know it's not ever any one thing it's
just you you have to make these
decisions which are hard but you feel
like hey they're gonna this is what's
gonna be the best for us in the long run
and so you know once we made that
decision and were able to get Teddy and
as you said I mean he's you know he's 27
years old he's he's taking a team to the
playoffs he's he's proven last year that
he still has everything that it takes
and so we just feel like you know what a
great opportunity to get him in here for
three years or three-year contract leave
a let him be our quarterback yeah fits
our system you know he knows Joe so well
they were both in New Orleans together
and and you know see what he can do and
I've just been so impressed with him you
know really throughout these these past
weeks you know I mean just you know as
we're touring things virtually he really
loves the game of football and you know
he talks about it you see him light up
and you can see the people already on
our team we are responding to him I
think I think he's gonna be really good
for us okay before I let you go Matt
rule um what was the first time you met
Tom Coughlin's give me give me give me
good story so I I decided to take the I
decide to take the temple job so I'm
there and I'm working for Coach Coughlin
and I take the temple job and he comes
in my office he says you take it you
know you're taking this job I said yes
sir yes sir I'm gonna take the temple
job he's kind of like you know gruff
like you know okay and he said to me he
says he says we better finish up a
season I said yes sir I will so that
night's the Christmas party and the
Mehra's and his family Christmas party
and Giants partying mrs. Coughlin Miss
Judy was one of the one of the most
wonderful woman in the world walks up
and she's like oh we are so happy for
Tom is so proud of you and I said I was
with Tom are you talking about and see I
said he didn't look like he wanted to go
up one side of me is down the other so
you know how calm is but he's really
really proud of you and that's really
cool Tom Coughlin is you know people see
him one way but he's just an amazing
amazing guy and I'm blessed to work for
he was you know did I hear you say that
you're still a little afraid of him did
I did I hear that when he called I like
straighten up I he always sat in the
same spot at the combine every year
right there on the 10-yard line he
wanted that 10-yard split at the 40 no
one was moving him off that spot and I
you know my job as you know host of NFL
Network evolved with Twitter and social
media to try and give fans an
opportunity to get behind the scenes you
know what's what's the name of the show
it still is on NFL Network called Total
Access so I felt like hey look this is
the event that few fans have access to
so I started taking pictures of what's
going on in the stands and I had the
temerity of training my this how long
ago was blackberry on Coach Coughlin and
he looked at me and said the following
come on rich you're better than that
[Laughter]
I still have you know flashbacks to that
moment what he said that to me I'm like
oh no that's no good you know so I know
exactly hey coach
thanks for the time really appreciate it
and again you still are not the the
question I asked you at this year's
combine as we quickly cross paths you
are not wearing a vest the bailer vest
is not coming soon ago I think I think
it had retired quickly is that is that
because it's not NFL issued are you just
like you know what that was then this is
now
yeah you know it's what I did it last
year at Baylor a kind of like I did it
as a little thing with the team and it
kind of grew and became a big deal and
at the end of the year you know had I
stayed I was gonna auction it off and
give the money to charity and hopefully
a bailiff saying would pay some money
for and then I was gonna head kind of
run its course so I showed up in
Carolina and they had one made for me
and I said no no I that was a one and
done so right unless unless unless I
changed my mind or something happens I
think I'll just kind of look like
everybody else well coach let's uh let's
keep in touch really appreciate it
and good luck with the next few weeks
and I cannot wait to talk football I
cannot wait to same here thank you
that's a Matt rule you got it's a head
coach the Carolina Panthers right here
in the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here